imágenes insólitas de una de las
principales estaciones ferroviarias de
la capital inglesa el London Bridge
miles de conductores de trenes asociados
al sindicato ingenieros de locomotoras y
bomberos pararon sus actividades y
entraron en el primer de dos días de
huelga la mayor en Reino Unido en más de
una década
a la red ferroviaria se sumaron los
maestros el personal universitario y los
funcionarios públicos
estamos pidiendo un aumento salarial a
prueba de la inflación de dos dígitos
para evitar que el salario de los
maestros se siga recortando este año
También queremos un reajuste salarial de
los maestros a largo plazo teniendo en
cuenta que la mayor cantidad de horas
extra que se trabaja no son remuneradas
los maestros afirman que en los últimos
12 años su salario ha caído un 13%,
dejándolos en crisis actualmente con una
inflación del 10,5% anual en diciembre
el costo de vida se ha encarecido para
todos los sectores de la economía
Mark secretario general del sindicato de
servicios públicos y comerciales
protesta porque su salario solo subió 2%
medio millón en huelga hoy significa que
si eres maestro maquinista conferencista
funcionario público o trabajador de la
salud no merece ser más pobre de lo que
eras al final del año
sin embargo el gobierno del conservador
parece no ceder aumentar los salarios
alentaría la espiral inflacionaria día
los manifestantes que sean conscientes
de la realidad económica de la nación
según estimaciones del fondo monetario
internacional la economía británica
sería la única del g7 en contraerse en
2023 registrando un decrecimiento del
0,6%
Se esperan más manifestaciones con una
nueva movilización de los trabajadores
del sector salud la próxima semana